[Musique]
Emmanuel Macron se rend en Bretagne
aujourd'hui après le passage de la
tempête kirane qui a balayé le pays
faisant de morts et de nombreux dégâts
aujourd'hui la situation est toujours
sous surveillance dans le Sud-Ouest et
en Corse Mathias Arz au lendemain du
passage de la tempête karane les
habitants de l'Ouest de la France ne
peuvent que constater les dégâts on a
passé une partie de la nuit sans toit
ouais ouais bah jusqu'à ce matin où on a
vraiment réalisé l'ampleur des dégâts
quoi hier le phénomène climatique a mis
en difficulté une partie du pays près
d'un million de foyers se sont retrouvé
sans électricité la tempête fait
plusieurs dizaines de blessés mais
également de morts ce vendredi cinq
départements parmi lesquels le Pas de
Calais les lande les Pyrénées
Atlantiques mais aussi la Corse reste en
vigilance orange dans un contexte encore
incertain la ministre de la transition
énergétique agès pagier runaché a fait
part de ses craintes concernant la
tempête doming
iné qui pourrait toucher la façade
atlantique des samedis une partie des
arbres auront été affaiblis à moitié des
raciné une partie des toitures auront
été fragilisé et donc on peut s'attendre
à avoir une deuxième phase d'épisode
avec là aussi un impact sur sur les
réseaux ce vendredi la première ministre
Elisabeth borne est en déplacement dans
le Calvados pour saluer les sapeurs
pompiers policiers gendarmes agents
territoriaux et élus locaux mobilisé
pendant l'épisode climatique 28e jour de
guerre entre Israël et le Hamas et
Israël a annoncé hier avoir achevé
l'encerclement de la ville de Gaza
Jérôme
Rabier Israël poursuit sa progression
dans la bande de Gaza et a réussi une
première étape importante en coupant le
nord de l'enclave palestinienne du reste
du
territoire ça l'chev l'encerclement de
la ville de Gaza centre de
l'organisation terroriste Hamas mais pas
question pour pour Israël d'en rester là
malgré les demandes de cesser le feu de
trêve ou de pause humanitair le Premier
ministre israélien a rappelé qu'un seul
but animer désormais l'État hébreu nous
sommes très déterminés à continuer à
atteindre l'objectif de la guerre qui
est de faire chuter le
Hamas la progression dans la bande de
Gaza se fait avec un appui aérien
toujours aussi intense les bombardements
continuent de se multiplier comme ici
hier à proximité d'une école de l'onu
une frappe qui fait près de 30 morts
selon le ministère de la Santé gazaou
tenu par le Hamas aujourd'hui les
regards devraient aussi se tourn vers le
nord du territoire de l'État hébreu à la
frontière
libano-israélienne où les frappes de
tsal répondent depuis le 7 octobre aux
attaques de roquet du Hezbollah libanais
dont le leader Hassan nasrala à la tête
de la milice chiite doit prononcer un
discours très attendu qui pourrait faire
monter encore un peu plus la tenstion
dans cette région
poudrier et le Liban où s'est rendu hier
le ministre des Armées Sébastien le cor
nu il est allé auprès des casques bleus
français de la force intérimaire des
Nations Unies au Liban la finule il a
mis en garde contre un risque d'escalade
dans la
région le Liban n'a pas besoin d'une
guerre c'est le moins que l'on puisse
dire sans compter que cette guerre pour
avoir des effets escalatoires importants
sur l'ensemble de la région donc la
finule elle est un des outil elle est
une solution elle n'est pas un problème
et le tribunal correctionnel de nî a
condamné hier un de Beer a 8 mois de
prison avec surcil pour apologie du
terrorisme et propos antisémite il avait
tenu sur les réseaux sociaux des propos
antisémite appelant à combattre les
Juifs et faisant l'apologie du
terrorisme dans le contexte actuel de
guerre entre Israël et le
[Musique]
Hamas merci à MAD law de nous
accompagner pendant cette première
demi-heure vous êtes nouvellement élu de
la scène saint membre du groupe RDSE
Rassemblement démocratique et social
européen et vous êtes également
vice-président national du Parti radical
de gauche on va commencer avec
l'actualité ce conflit entre Israël et
le Hamas et ses répercussions dans notre
pays et notamment ces étoiles de David
qui ont été retrouvées taguées sur des
immeubles à Paris mais aussi dans votre
département à saint-toin à Saint-Denis à
aubervillier et Gérald harmanin qui a
dit que 857 actes antisémites avaient
été commis depuis le 7 octobre comment
on lutte contre cette résurgence de
l'antisémitisme ben écoutez on la combat
déjà parce que je pense que l'
l'antisémitisme ou le racisme euh donc
et comment et il y a une loi qui était
qui a été votée hein par par par le par
le Sénat et par les par l'Assemblée
nationale pour condamner et combattre
l'antisémitisme et le racisme et donc
par tous les moyens il faut il faut le
dénoncer euh après la question qui se
pose aujourd'hui c'est
euh cette situation là est une
exportation du conflit
israëlo-palestinien en France moi ce que
je veux pas c'est que ce conflit-l
arrive arrive en France aujourd'hui on
est dans un pays qui est la France qui
est une France républicaine laïque et
humaniste et donc à partir de là je
pense que le message qu'on doit porter
c'est chacun doit vivre ensemble en
fonction de sa religion en fonction de
de sa nationalité et donc dans ce pays
qui est très beau qu'un pays qui a reçu
toutes les nation toutes les personnes
toutes l'immigration depuis très très
longtemps et je pense que là-dessus
c'est là-dessus qu'il faut que que que
nous élus politiques passons le message
pour que cela ne soit pas une situation
qui dégénère mais il est pas déjà
importé pour vous ce conflit bah écoutez
moi ce que je souhaite c'est qu'il soit
pas soit pas importé parce que je pense
que aujourd'hui c'est pas une guerre de
religion c'est une guerre de territoire
d'accord euh cette guerre de territoire
a démarré en
1947 et donc à partir de là
euh chacun des États a essayé par tous
les moyens de de de gérer et de faire en
sorte qu'il y ait des pais entre les
deux entre l'État d'Israël et entre
l'État palestinien
toujours avec une situation qui fait
qu'à chaque fois certains terroristes
que ça soit du Hamas ou que ça soit
j'irais le gouvernement d'extrême droite
israélien n'ont souhaité cette paix moi
ce que je souhaite c'est qu'à un moment
donné qu'on tourne la parabole vers
d'autres personnes qui aujourd'hui sont
je dirais gouvernent que ce soit enfin
qui sont dans l'étatisraël ou dans
l'état palestinien je prends par exemple
le le le le fata où on a laissé tomber
tout ça
d'un revers de main parce que c'était
eux les interlocuteurs ils ont été ils
sont reconnus au niveau sur le plan
international ils sont reconnus au
niveau de l'ONU et donc à partir de là
c'est avec eux qu'il faut discuter sauf
que aujourd'hui moi je je renvoie dos à
dos que ça soit le hamass ou que ça soit
l'extrême tréen c'est cette cette
tragédie humanitaire c'est pour ça que
je demande aujourd'hui qu'il y ait
vraiment une trêve humanitaire qui soit
fait le plus plus urgemment possible
demand Emmanuel Macron voilà et et
d'autre part je demande aussi à l'Europe
qui a aussi son moi à dire pour essayer
de qui pèse vraiment ben j'espère qu'il
pèse vraiment je ne souhaiterais pas que
on est plus proche du moyen-orant que
les États-Unis donc à partir il faut que
aussi l'Europe soit aussi porteur de
messages de paix qui permettent que dans
ce dans ce dans ce dans ce dans cette
région qui est des États à part entière
les citoyens palestiniens le souhaitent
les citoyens israéliens le souhaitent on
va parler d'un autre sujet d'actualité à
partir de lundi vous allez examiner le
projet de loi immigration Gérald armanin
dit qu'il tient à l'article 3 sur la
régularisation des travailleurs dans les
métiers tention mais en même temps c'est
la ligne rouge des républicains est-ce
que vous pensez que cet article sera
maintenu dans le texte écoutez moi je
pense que LR est dans une
situation qui fait que il est dans une
démarche de course à l'échalotte
d'accord c'est-à-dire que avec qui avec
le rassemblement national le
rassemblement national je dire
aujourd'hui tape sur la tape matin midi
soir sur
l'immigration les LR suivent je dirais
les proposition encore des proposions du
RN et donc à partir de là les Français
le savent entre la photocopie enfin
l'original et la copie les gens les gens
préfèrent l'original et donc ils sont en
train de courir après que les sondages
montrent que les Français soutiennent ce
projet de loi immigration ou mais
attendez ils soutiennent parce qu'ils
connaissent pas les contours aujourd'hui
excusez-moi mais moi j'ai pris le train
le rorb ce matin la plupart des imig son
travail aujourd'hui dans les dans prenez
moi je demande aux sénateurs et aux
députés de LR d'aller le matin dans le
rorb il vont voir les personnes qui vont
travailler le matin pour cette pour pour
notre pays et donc à un moment donné ces
gens-là la plupart ne sont pas
régularisés ils travaill depuis un
certain temps donc on va les laisser on
va les laisser comme ça c'est pendant un
certain temps en sachant qu'en plus moi
je suis dans un département comme vous
le savez qui l'année prochaine va
accueillir les Jeux olympiques tous les
groupes les grands groupes groupe de
bâtiments aujourd'hui recrute qui ils
ont plus personne donc ils recrutent
parout les moyens et donc des fois vous
avez des gens qui travaillent qui sont
sans papier donc qu'est-ce qu'on fait on
les régularise pas vous vous demandez la
régularisation de tous les travailles
pass uniquement dans les métiers en
tenstion comme c'est dit dans le texte
nous voilà on souhaite qu'à un moment
donné pour des personnes qui sont là
depuis un certain temps depuis plus de
20 mois ou 30 mois qui travaillent qui
ont une un contrat de travail qui qui
qui qui uvre pour pour l'autre pays
d'être régularisé et bien sûr pour les
métiers en tension on souhaite que
chaque année on revoit parce que vous
dites on pourra pas faire les Jos sans
ses travailleurs c'est pas qu'on va pas
pouvoir c'est que allez voir le groupe
Fage ou d'autres groupes et vous verrez
et allez moi je demande aux sénateurs et
aux députés d'aller sur le terrain et de
voir réellement qui travaille et qui
nous le diront faut pas qu'ils viennent
faire du show business sur dans les
hémicycles et de ne pas regarder
réellement ils font du show business
pour vous bah pour moi c'est c'est c'est
c'est en gros c'est ils essayent de
monter d'essayer de de de de monter je
dirais d' d'être plus haut que le Front
national enfin d'être plus haut que le
rassemblement national mais je vous dis
de courir après le rassemblement
national c'est pas ce qu'il est fa qu'
ser fera gagner on est dans un pays
humaniste on est dans un pays
républicain on est dans un pays laïque
on est dans un pays où à un moment donné
on a toujours accueilli une immigration
depuis plus de plus plus de 50 ans je
vois pas aujourd'hui Pourquoi on montre
du doigt ces personnesl qui souhaitent
s'intégrer dans notre pays et travailler
pour notre pays on va passer à un autre
sujet la semaine dernière ellisabeth
borne présenter ses mesures en réponse
aux émeutes qui ont touché le pays au
début de l'été des émeutes qui avaient
un visage différent elles ont concerné
beaucoup les petites îles et les villes
moyennes c'est à ce sujet que s'est
intéressé notre journaliste Jonathan
Dupri son documentaire ville moyenne
l'autre visage des émeutes est diffusé
demain à 18h30 sur notre antenne
Jonathan vient nous
[Musique]
rejoindre bonjour Jonathan bonjour et
Jonathan venez donc de réaliser un
reportage de 26 minutes diffusé demain
sur la suite des émeutes urbaines de
juillet et vous avez pris le parti de
poser votre caméra dans un territoire
qu'on assimile peu au violents sururbain
ouis exactement Ryan on a choisi de
sillonner la Loire alors la Loire pas le
fleuve la loire autour de Saint-Étienne
il nous est apparu assez saillant de
mettre en lumière le cas de trois
communes
particulièrement touché de de ce
territoire Rohan laricamari rive de GI
ça vous dit peut-être rien mais Séville
ont connu des violences urbaines très
importantes et elle-même n'y étaient pas
du tout habitué et des même qu'on peut
qualifier d'ultraviolence en plein
centre-ville la particularité de ces
endroits c'est comme dans beaucoup de
territoires périphériques les émeutes
sont arrivés avec un peu plus de latence
que dans les les grandes métropoles donc
environ 3 jours après la mort du jeune
Naël vers le le 30 juin et donc c'est il
y a eu des nuits de de violence très
très courtes et mais très intense ça a
duré de TR jours et puis le le calme est
revenu et donc on s'attarde notamment
sur le le cas de la ville de rive de
Giet qui est une ville de 15000
habitants ancien ancienne cité minière
et qui a été vraiment sidérée par les
émeutes et donc on y retournait 4 mois
après et le traumatisme est encore très
très vif chez chez les habitants chez
les commerçants qui ont été attaqués
dans le centreville et je vous propose
d'écouter cet
extrait dans sa boutique du centre-ville
de rive de giier Sandra Pula s'efforce
de retrouver un quotidien normal ça je
pense que ça va plaire à pas mal de de
garçon en juin dernier la gérante de 57
ans a vécu plusieurs nuits de cauchemars
des hémetiers ont saccagé et pillé son
commerce ça c'était le premier soir donc
le 30
[Applaudissements]
juin au total 25000 € de marchandis
dérobé et 17000 € de vitrine brisée la
commerçante a failli baisser les bras et
quitter la ville et et aujourd'hui c'est
hors de question pour vous de vous dire
voilà ma boutique je vais je vais la
déplacer on va aller d'illeurs alors ça
j'ai eu une réflexion de de quelques
jours où j'étais complètement perdu et
comment vous dire ça c'est une question
je fallait pas me poser
pardon j'y arrive pas c'est trop dur si
ça a été compliqué et Jonathan le cas de
rive de J est emblématique sa mairie a
été incendiée c'est une des partic
particularité de cestins ouais tout à
fait Orian c'est l'un des enseignements
c'est que la violence envers les
symboles de l'État a pris une ampleur
inédite hein dans cette crise en 8 jours
seulement il y a 105 mairies qui ont été
attaquées sur l'ensemble du pays c'est
242 bâtiments public hein tout confondu
donc avec on peut ajouter les les écoles
aussi dedans et dans les édifices les
plus touchés au niveau national il y a
cette fameuse mairie de rive de giier où
on a posé notre caméra c'est 3 millions
de dégâts rien que pour ce bâtiment 7
millions pour la ville au total et le 30
juin donc il y a des dizaines de de très
très jeunes émetiers qui se sont donnés
rendez-vous sur le réseau social
snapchat euh ils ont aspergé d'essence
des poubelles et qui ont ensuite
enflammé ce ce bâtiment qui est vieux de
200 ans euh et les pompiers à 15 minutes
près voilà parviennent à contenir le le
brasier mais le le bâtiment tout entier
aurait aurait pu vraiment flamber et
donc le soir de l'attaque le maire
Vincent Bonny très vite se rend sur les
lieux euh il essaie même de s'interposer
devant les éémetiers euh il se fait
copieusement insulter comme il nous
l'avait raconter et en tout cas il
n'arrive pas à sauver l'édifice et il
nous fait en tout cas le film de cette
soir catastrophe et je vous propose
d'écouter ce
moment ici tout a pris feu les flammes
sont monté le long des murs et puis ces
fumées noir épaisses se sont accumulé
ici au deè étage et la chaleur dégondé
les portes ça pollu l'ensemble des
locaux de l'hôtel de ville ça fait tout
le câblage électrique toute
l'informatique C été un vrai désastre
quand on est rentrer là-dedans on le
sentiment de d'être dans une scène de
film c'était incroyable paysage calciné
quoi voilà les dégâts estimés à 3
millions d'euros font partie des plus
importants au niveau national à rive de
jier la moitié de l'hôtel de ville est
aujourd'hui
impraticable j'ai pas les mots j'ai pas
les
mots c'est comme si un ouragan était
passé je sais pas je sais pas comment
expliquer et puis on est on est face à
ce déferlement qui n'a aucun rapport
avec la vie commune ici avec la vie de
la
commune et bah on doit subir ça et on
doit faire face quoi voà tout simplement
on doit faire face Ahmed lawch ce sont
des mairies jeonathan disé qui ont été
attaqués on entend ce maire dire qu'il
n'a pas les mots dans le reportage de
Jonathan Cécile cuckerman qui est la
sénatrice parle d'élu déboussolé de Mar
qui ont pris une claque est-ce que c'est
aussi les retours que vous avez eu oui
bien sûr toute façon c'est les dégâts
qui ont eu c'est inacceptable on ne peut
pas de toute façon accepter cela quoi
d'où d'où d'où ils viennent que ce soit
les commerçants que ce soit les service
public que ça soit les les je dirais les
tout ce qui œuvre pour je dirais un lien
social dans dans dans ces territoires la
seule chose c'est que cet étincell-là
qui a explosé face à une situation de la
mort d'un jeune je pense que c'est ça
qui a fait l'étincelle mais c'est pas
réellement ce cette problématique là
cette problématique est là depuis
longtemps euh moi d'ailleurs je je rends
hommage aux élus hein de terrain qui
sont aujourd'hui qui font un travail
excellent dans le dans dans le
département dont je suis sénateur qui
est laassen San que ça soit les maires
ou ou ou les conseillers municipaux
parce que ils uvrent pour mais sur ces
maires aujourd'hui est-ce que les vous
les côtoyez forcément est-ce que ce sont
des mairres qui ont qui sont découragés
non pas du tout je ne pense pas les ma
encienne saint n enfin pour ce qui qui
ce qui concerne mon territoire ils sont
pas découragés au contraire ils sont là
pour essayer de trouver des solutions
par contre moi moi ce que je dis
aujourd'hui c'est que les solutions qui
ont été qui sont trouvées par les maires
doivent être financées aujourd'hui
l'État se désengage de plus en plus
aujourd'hui l'État que ça soit en
matière éducatif au niveau des écoles
des établissements scolaires c'est là où
c'est la force qui doit être en priorité
dans nos territoires n'est pas considéré
deuxièmement le lien social avec le
monde associatif qu'on a laisser d'un
revers de main de côté et qu'on a pas
aidé remett en place les conseils locaux
de la PR tion de délinquence qui ont été
retiré voilà et donc à partir de là
c'est vrai que vous avez certains maires
aujourd'hui conseil qui se retrouvent
seul face face à une situation sans aide
de l'État et ça et ça et ça ça doit être
ça doit être revu par par le
gouvernement tout à l'heure je me rends
à HN sousbois où la ministre de la Ville
se rend pour aller rencontrer une
association qui œuvre pour
l'entrepreneuriat qui s'appelle CRÉO
académie voilà c'est ça qu'il faut faire
c'est soutenir l'entrepreneuriat dans
ces quartiers pour pouvoir faire en
sorte parce que ce qu'ils ont casser les
jeunes aujourd'hui vous avez vu c'est du
matériel c'est euh tout ce qui est
vêtement donc ça un rapport avec
l'argent il faut il faut il faut il faut
il faut il faut le dire clairement donc
là il y a peut-être quelque chose qui
doit être revu et vous dites les maires
les maires ils sentent seuls euh les
assureurs sont en train de de lâcher
beaucoup de mairies notamment cette
mairie de de rive de giier son
assureur avait une clause émeute tant
mieux pour eux donc ils sont ils vont
être pris en charge mais l'assurance lui
le lui a communiqué au maire que voilà
en fait le contrat n'allait pas être
renouvelé il ne savent pas comment ils
vont en avoir estce que vous vous avez
eu des remontées de terrain de de Mair
justement qui eux aussi sont sont lâchés
par leurs Assur alors j'ai pas eu de
retour hein parce que je suis pas dans
le sur sur sur personne me m'a m'a
informé de de C de cette situation là
mais à un moment donné les assurances
doivent prendre leur responsabilité euh
il faut pas faire en sorte qu'à chaque
fois qu'il y ait quelque chose qu'on
disent ah non ah non non mais nous on
finance pas non parce que quand quand
quand quand la collectivité territoriale
pay l' assurance elle doit avoir elle
doit être assurée après vous avez l'état
aussi qui revient qui peut venir aussi
en soutien mais euh je pense je pense
qu'à moment donné ce genre de chose doit
être euh euh mis devant les instances
judiciaires pour condamner les assureurs
qui veulent pas prendre en charge les
dégâts alors ça c'est une chose après il
y a aussi les dégâts quand j'entends euh
la ministre qui dit qu'il faut faire
payer euh les hémetiers attendez on a
une situation aujourd'hui qui fait que
euh vous allez demander à des personnes
de famille monoparental qui aujourd'hui
sont dans une situation de détresse et
c'est vrai qu'on a vu les jeunes qui on
fait ça c'est pas des jeunes DEP plus 18
ans c'est des jeunes de 14 ans à 18 ans
donc ça veut dire qu'à un moment donné
il y a une responsabilité des parents
moi
je moment donné les parents ont une
responsabilité mais dans ces secteurs là
dans ces territoires là où la famille
est seule à élever leurs enfants ils
partent le matin ils reviennent le soir
là il faudra peut-être retrouver un un
lien un lien soci si je prends par
exemple la maison des parentalités qui
est dans certaines collectivités Teral
ça existe il faut que l'État prenne en
compte ce JRE parce que si s'il le
prennent pas aujourd'hui demain ça sera
encore pire on va parler des réponses
puisque Jonathan on le voit dans votre
reportage les Maes en première ligne
pendant les émeutes sont aussi les
premiers à tenter d'apporter des
réponses sur le terrain avant même
l'état oui parce qu'en fait les élus
locaux ben ils ont les les deux pieds
dans la glaise si on peut dire ils sont
dans les réalité quotidienne et donc ils
ont pas vraiment le temps d'attendre et
leurs administrés non plus on le sent
c'est très av par exemple ça arrive de
jier on est on est sur le marché les les
les habitants ils interpellent le maire
il il leur parl des dégâts il leur parle
de la mairie ça a choqué tout le monde
et donc 4 mois après on n toujours passé
à autre chose en vérité donc ces émeutes
elles ont aussi jeté une lumière assez
crue sur certaines carences de l'État à
plusieurs niveaux en matière d'éducation
de service publics qui sont parfois
absents de ces territoires et et donc
c'est c'est aussi une des une des
raisons de cette déconnexion parfois
même avec les les symboolle de l'État
mais il y a aussi évidemment et c'est de
là que par la la la crise c'est le lien
entre la police c'est la population
est-ce que remonte beaucoup d'élus et
ben c'est simplement aussi une présence
policière bien insuffisante sur le
territoire des finalement des des agents
de police qu'on ne voit pas parce
queussi ces territoires sont inégalement
dotés en en effectif et donc nous on
s'est rendu à Ran donc au nord de la
Loire qui est la souspréfecture du
département et cette ville elle a choisi
donc d'opter un peu pour la méthode
forte si l'on peut dire plus de bleu
dans la rue pour que la sécurité soit
plus visible et assurer de la sérénité à
certains quartiers et donc le maire va
recruter 12 iciers municipaux ce qui
représente quand même une somme de
500000 € sur le budget de sa commune
sans aide de l'État et écoutez y Nicolin
sujet direction ran la Sous-Préfecture
de la Loire dans cette ville de 35000
habitants le maire y Nicolin a fait de
la police municipale la pierre angulaire
de sa réponse post
émeute bonjour mesdames bonjour monsieur
le ma mais c'est féminin ce matin 26
agents armés et bien équipés UNECE vis
de proximité amené à compenser le recul
des forces de sécurité régalienne sur le
terrain la grande difficulté de la
police nationale c'est queelle a
beaucoup d'effectifs notamment à roa
nous avons plus de 140 fonctionnaires
sur le commissariat mais une grande
partie de ces effectifs est consacré à
une tâche d'enquête une tâche
administrative donc nos effectifs sont
plus présents sur le terrain que ne peut
l'être la police nationale avec les
moyens dont elle dispose si l'on veut
notamment dans certains quartiers avoir
davantage de sérénité il faut qu'on ait
aussi davantage de présence policière et
ça c'est une question
d'effectif bonjour alors qu'est-ce qu'il
y a comme équipement là bah toujours
pareil monsie le maire c'est quoi ça
c'est bah c'est ce qui nous a sauvé la
semaine dernière gaz ah oui gaz en êtes
fier Monsieur le Maire de votre police
municipale ah oui Amel la sur le rôle
des polices municipales puisqu'il en a
été question pendant ces émeutes l'une
des réponses du gouvernement c'est
d'augmenter le rôle et les pouvoirs de
ces polices municipales c'est la bonne
réponse écoutez vous l'avez dans votre
reportage c'est la police municipale qui
a remplacé la police régalienne est-ce
que c'est normal non d'accord une police
régalienne ça doit être une police
régalienne avec des moyens nécessairire
les policiers aussi sont dans une
situation de détresse d'ailleurs bah ils
font aussi leur travail comme % des
forces de sécurité ils font leur travail
ils font leur travail comme ils peuvent
oui c'est 10 % sauf qu'on a laissé et
certains maires ont joué le choix enfin
ont fait le choix pardon on fait le
choix d'aller vers la police municipale
donc moi j'aurais pas fait ça j'aurais
d'abord fait en sorte que c'est pas que
pas un bon Cho c'est que l'État se
désengage de plus en plus et donc à
partir de là c'est les collectivités
territoriales un policier municipal ça
coûte très cher à la ville vous le savez
ça coûte très cher donc et quand vous
voyez les budgets de la ville dans une
collectivité territoriale la sécurité
c'est 30 à 40 % d'accord du budget de la
ville d'une ville donc ça c'est aussi
cet argent là qui aurait dû être donné
par l'État après police de proximité
excusez-moi mais quand il y avait la
police de proximité l'époque il y avait
un discours qui était tenu il y avait un
un une des rencontres jeunes police qui
se faisaient et qui avait un un travail
d'animation d'été où vous aviez des vous
aviez des des policiers de toute la
France qui venaient dans le cadre de
villeevie vacances aller à la à à la
rencontre des jeunes pour discuter pour
se pour pour essayer de qu'il y ait
vraiment une discussion il ça ça a été
rompu par qui par les gouvernement
successif je remets pas en cause ni le
gouvernement socialiste ni le
gouvernement enfin je remets en cause
gouvernement exc-m jeets en cause le
gouvernement socialiste et le
gouvernement de Nicolas sarzi qui ont
fait en sorte de de de ne pas continuer
ce dialogue qui aurait permis moi je
pense réellement un lien avec ces jeunes
de nos
territoires actuellement et aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce qui se passe ben
malheureusement qui sont dans les
territoires aujourd'hui et qui gèrent
ces territoires là c'est les caites de
la
drogue et donc c'est pas normal il faut
que la République revienne dans les
territoires ouais c'est c'est juste par
parce que Jonathan le maire de la
ramarie le dit dans votre reportage que
le le trafic de drogue c'est la source
de toutes les nuisances et bien sûr mais
bien sûr complètement entre entre entre
les caïes de la dro vous avez remarqué
quand même que au bout de 3 jours ça
s'est éteint les émeut mais ça éteint
pourquoi parce que les ces de la drogue
à un moment donné perdaient de l'argent
et donc à un moment donné ils ont dit Oh
stop on arrête c'est ça qui dit
làuss ça se dit dans toute la France
c'est pas que c'est pas que cela dans
votre reportage et donc à partir de là
il faut qu' aussi qu'il ait réellement
un combat réel de la de la de la de la
de la de la de la police enfin un combat
pour de la police contre contre ces ces
de la dro qui font aujourd'hui main
basse dans les territoires de la
République et là ce qui est sous-jacent
à ce qu'on vient de voir là à Ran c'est
quand même que Ran c'est une
sous-préfecture donc ran a quand même
donc 35000 habitants c'est une ville
quand même qui a des moyen donc le maire
peut se permettre de d'investir et de
voilà de mettre 500000 € sur la table il
peut il peut peut le faire en revanche
il y a des communes de 8000 habitants
voilà vous parlez de La Ricamarie Orian
ou rive de giier 15000 habitants déjà
eux ne ne peuvent pas du tout faire ça
donc le risque aussi c'est que ça
renforce une certaine forme si on
renforce la police municipale
mécaniquement ça va renforcer les villes
qui sont les mieux doté qui ont en tout
cas plus de moyens plus de marges de Man
moi la proposition que je fais c'est que
la police municipale si les villes on
ont besoin parce que l'État n'a pas la
possibilité de recruter que ces
policiers municipaux soient réglés payés
par l'État donc c'est permet ça permett
ça permettrait que un moment donné
l'argent qui est donné à la sécurité
soit donné à autre chose pour pour vous
pour qu'on comprenne bien la les
réponses qui ont été apportées par le
gouvernement la semaine dernière ce ne
sont pas les bonnes alors excusez-moi
c'est pas que c'est pas les bonnes c'est
qu'à mon avis ça ça va pas être suivi
des faits moi j'entends j'attends
j'attends de savoir comment ça va se
mettre en place mais moi à mon avis
c'est de l'annonce et rien de l'annonce
et c'est là où j'alerte attention parce
que ce genre d'émeut peut revenir
d'accord et ce que je vous dis c'est moi
je crois que l'ensemble des acteurs
publics associatifs doivent se mettre
autour d'une table je sais pas organisé
par l'État par les les régions les
départements pour qu'àun moment donné on
trouve réellement des solutions à cette
à à ces émeutes parce que on a laissé on
on laisse encore une fois et des choses
bah qui sont qui sont à mon avis qui
peuvent être graves pour l'avenir merci
Jonathan merci votre reportage il est
avir demain à 18h30 sur notre antenne et
il a également retrouvé sur notre site
Internet et sur nos réseaux sociaux
merci beaucoup merci Jonathan d'avoir
été avec nous un dernier mot plus
politique AHM lawedge avec vous puisque
on le disait vous êtes vice-président
national du du Parti radical de gauche
est-ce qu'il faut que la gauche rompe
définitivement avec Jean-Luc Mélenchon
écoutez nous on était pas dans l'accord
nupes lors des élections législatives on
a présenté
des candidats partout en France pour
mettre en avant notre notre politique et
notre
propositions du PRG centregauche donc
voilà donc moi je vais pas rentrer dans
dans le fait
que de taper sur jeanluc mlon pour taper
sur Jean-Luc Mélenchon sauf que ceux qui
aujourd'hui sortent de la nupes étai
quand même avec lui lors des
législatives mais il on avec est-ce que
pour être clair est-ce que si le PS rond
avec Jean-Luc Mélenchon le PRG pour à
nouveau retrouver un accord avec le PS
non mais attendez moi je sais je ça je
ne sais pas ça ça sera le président
Lacroix verra ça avec les instances
nationales du Parti socialiste mais
encore une fois à l'époque on leur avait
dit que il fallait qu'àun moment donné
que cette union de la gauche soit large
et qui soit à moment donné porte porteur
de de de de de messages importants au
niveau de de de des des habitants de nos
territoirees sauf que à un moment donné
ces gens-là ont fait en sorte de se
faire élire parce que si il se faisaient
pas élire avec Jean-Luc Mélenchon
c'était la mort de leur parti politique
et aujourd'hui le fait qu'ils ont été
élus et qu'aujourd'hui ils disent oh là
là attention ça chauffe allez on sort de
là non non la politique c'est pas ça la
politique c'est des convictions la
politique c'est des solutions la
politique c'est faire en sorte qu'à un
moment donné on puisse être je dirais
force de proposition pour que les
habitants de de nos territoires et
réellement quelque chose de concret à à
leur à leur à leur à leur proposer pas
de leur pas faire encore une FO comme
j'ai du showbsiness et de se faire
élir pour avec les les copains et les
coquins merci Ahed lawge merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec nous et merci Jonathan
également d'avoir été là ce matin